[Musique]
waouh
les amis aujourd'hui est un jour spécial
car je peux enfin vous parlez de tourner
la page mon livre merci ouah c'est
original bravo c'est pas comme si tous
les deux tubes heures l'avait fait avant
toi en plus on n'a pas déjà sorti à la
le machin book
alors non c'est vraiment mon premier
livre j'avais par contre peut customiser
dix pages d'un agenda et d'un notebook
chez carrefour mais ça n'a rien à voir
avec un livre ok mais ton livre c'est
toi qui l'a écrit pour moi c'est
totalement mois qu'il est écrit mais pas
un seul je l'écris avec maxence que vous
connaissez bien non en fait après le
premier livre de youtube heures en
france je crois que tu es celui des jo
phoenix tous les éditeurs m'ont contacté
pour me dire il ya enfin livre je vous
donne l'idée on fait tout pour toi
or ce à quoi j'ai répondu non c'est
pourquoi j'ai trop d'ego pour ne pas
écrire moi-même mon livre c'est évident
donc j'attends des bons moments
j'attendais trouver une idée qui me
plaisait en fait et ça a été le cas pour
tourner la page dès que j'ai vidé j'ai
contacté maxence ça l'a fait kiffer et
on a écrit tout ça à deux c'était génial
des bons moments et pourquoi ils
s'appellent tourner la page c'est une
référence au titre aguicheur qu'on peut
trouver un peu partout sur youtube y
compris sur ma chaîne je trouvais ça
marrant devait tourner la page et de
simuler un morceau de la page d'après
qui dépasse ou du coup tu vas tu
attendras un truc en tournant la page
h10 pas ce qui se passe je le bats spoil
mais du coup c'est quoi ton libre en
fête en gros c'est une sorte de livre
interactif saison de cahiers de vacances
pour ados et jeunes adultes dont des
gens comme moi et vous en gros dans
livia 36 des chaque idée est illustrée
par un énoncé qui vous dit quoi faire et
à côté une illustration quand je dis une
illustration c'est assez vagues parfois
vous allez devoir dessiner sur
l'illustration vous allez devoir l'a
découpé par faisait juste la lire et
vous amuser si j'ai bien fait mon
travail
donc ouais je pense qu'on peut mettre ça
dans les catégories livre interactif
slash qu'être vacances slash livre qu'il
faut acheter absolument slash pour la
fin d'année ok et qui a fait les
illustrations du coup parce que c'est
toi j'achète clairement pas tu insinue
que je dessine mal oui tu as totalement
raison
rassurez-vous si j'avais fait les élus
ça ressemblerait à ça certains réussi à
le reconnaître sur twitter c'est le
style de mon frère c'est mon frère qui a
fait toutes les illustrations du livre à
penser que savent pas mon frère dans la
vie et illustrateurs et c'est lui qui a
fait notamment ma photo youtube ma
bannière youtube aimons-nous trop
youtube du coup vous pouvez vous faire
une idée d'à quoi vous ressemblez les
élus mais bon dans le doute je vous en
mets quand même 2 3 par ci par là et on
arrête après ça se paye un peu trop
livre je suis trop content du livre et
du résultat de ce que c'est par rapport
à ce que j'avais imaginé parce que c'est
beaucoup mieux que ce que j'avais
imaginé grâce à mon frère qui a fait
toutes les élus qui des fois validé nos
idées ou des fois nous disait on les
mecs pas ouf du coup grâce à lui dans le
livre
les meilleures idées et surtout toutes
les idées sont illustrés mais d'une
manière incroyable j'adore le style de
mon frère est chaud objectifs ou pas
trop vu que c'est mon frère mais
vraiment je trouve qu'il a un talent fou
donc merci fleuron cher d'avoir accepté
de bosser sur ça avec moi je sais que ça
a pris beaucoup de temps que tu as dû
beaucoup bossé que tu as eu des cheveux
blancs mais mec regard le résultat
[ __ ] regardez on va on va l'appeler on
lui a demandé si vous êtes libre
bref vieux tu es content du résultat du
livre et bien c'est super j'étais en
pleine vidéo tu viens de dire à tout le
monde avec sincérité que tu l'aimés
tournée tu es vraiment dire aux gens
qu'il est génial c'est naturellement on
sait très bien tu dis pas ça parce que
tu veux qu'ils se vendent pour toucher
un maximum d'argent quand même à il est
comme son frère soyez là c'est
incroyable
bref pour te répondre voix off hyper
chiante c'est mon frère qui a fait les
élus plait-il non non j'ai dit vous voix
off très agréable et on peut l'acheter
ou ton livre est bon partout vous pouvez
le commander en ligne entre autres sur
amazon et la fnac espère les disposant
tous les magasins qui vendent des livres
donc la fnac à la fnac
toutes les librairies etc ok c'est juste
pour dire mais pas de ne pas l'acheter
s'il tombe dessus
ah je lâchais pas coutume on met plein
la gueule tout à l'heure je l'achèterai
pas je ne l'achète pas twilight et
religieux de faire bouffer tous plus il
est tellement bien ce livre que même à
manger salaires agréable acheter tourner
la page eh bien vous savez tout à et un
dernier truc dont je vous parlais c'est
que je donne un hashtag le hashtag
tourner la page n'hésitez pas à prendre
en photo les pages de votre livre où
vous allez devoir dessiner et on ferait
une vidéo avec maxence dans quelques
semaines pour regarder tout ce que vous
avez fait avec le livre en fait voilà
c'est une petite idée qu'on a eus quitte
à ce que vous deviez dessiner des fois
où créer un truc
grâce au livre pas autant qu'on voit ce
que vous avez fait et ben voila j'ai
hésité pas si vous l'achetez à me faire
un petit tweet on dire ce que vous en ai
vu que ce que vous en eau le mcp dans
les villes ce même pas parler trop dire
ce que vous en avez pensé voilà j'étais
tout ce que j'avais à dire je remercie a
repris temps de regarder cette vidéo je
vous dis à très dans une prochaine
j'espère ça vous plaire de tout coeur
mais j'ai pas trop de doute je pense que
vous avez passé un bon moment à perdre
sa prochaine vidéo à et moi je vais
tourner la page mais hors caméra pour
pas vous spoiler
[Musique]